vié bourg qui est contre la science et
le vite
la séance est levée passé on se devait
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle mouniama j'oublie
je suis député de la 6e circonscription
de paris ça correspond au xixème
arrondissement porte d'aubervilliers
part de la ville est belle ville
aujourd'hui les habitants de ma
circonscription vivent une situation
très particulière
on concentre aujourd'hui une des plus
grandes populations de toxicomanes liés
au crack et ça ça a des implications
dans le quotidien est aujourd'hui en
tant que député depuis plusieurs mois
depuis plus d'un an et demi j'ai essayé
de m'engager pour apporter des solutions
avec les forces de l'état et avec la
ville
mounir mahjoubi est un pur parisien
députés des quartiers populaires du
nord-est de la ville à la porte
d'aubervilliers il est sur ses terres
cette partie de sa circonscription est
en pleine mutation
un centre commercial neuf avec arrêt
résidence ça c'est pour la façade mais
dans tous les recoins prospère l'un des
pires fléaux de la capitale le crack
faouzi habitants du quartier montre
régulièrement aux députés les nouveaux
lieux de consommation et de vente
c'est un peu son lanceur dallaire cette
camionnette de chantier est ce second
appel dans le quartier une craque mobile
à l'intérieur se cache une réalité
sorti dans steam de crack mobile c'est
là qu'on y va pour fumer sa pipe de
crack c'est là où on va pour manger
parfois c'est là où ça peut être très
graves ont lieu des passes de
prostitution par des personnes craqué à
l'arrière du véhicule
et puis ça sert aussi de lieu de
déjections sa concentre tous les
problèmes du crack et pour les habitants
au dessus c'est insupportable on a toute
une population de craquer qui vit parmi
nous avec nous oblige à cohabiter
dans mon entreprise par des gens une
entreprise sous les yeux des habitants
ces scènes quotidiennes des toxicomanes
qui s'échangent des pipes fumantes
le crack est un dérivé hyper addictif de
la cocaïne
la dose est vendu autour de 15 euros les
usagers sont pour la plupart des
socialiser prêt à tout pour se fournir
ils investissent tous les lieux à l'abri
des regards comme ce parking de centre
commercial
on a consommé de la mort ici la vigile
privé des différentes entreprises et des
différents immeubles ont fait près de
100 interventions par semaine ici dans
ce bloc pour sortir les gens de ces
parkings
parce qu'encore une fois on est dans des
lieux qui sont un peu la fin de la ville
qui sont peu protégées où il ya peu
d'activités et qui sont peu connecté au
reste forcément pour des personnes
toxicomanes qui cherche à trouver des
lieux pour ela comme vous le voyez ça a
certainement servi de lieu de
prostitution des lieux pour se cacher
quant au point de vente pas besoin de
chercher bien loin
cette station de tramway vous voyez
juste ici elle a été pendant plusieurs
semaines un lieu de vente quasi
quotidiens où vous aviez 5 à 10
personnes installées et qui vendait du
tract on est dans une situation unique
en france
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas un seul
autre endroit où il ya trois cents
toxicomanes installés de façon
définitive au milieu de deux mille
familles à deux kilomètres de là le
canal de l'ourcq un autre visage de la
circonscription plus proche du paris des
cartes postales mais tout aussi exposé
aux ravages du crack
les toxicomanes ici se regroupent sur
les rives sous l'emprise de la drogue
ils sont imprévisibles
parfois violents pour les riverains ce
spectacle est un calvaire il éprouve le
besoin d'en parler et le député s'est
imposé comme un interlocuteur privilégié
corinne habite dans le quartier depuis
15 ans les toxicomanes en bas de chez
elle elle connaît bien mais si elle
rencontre mounir mahjoubi aujourd'hui
c'est pour lui raconter une expérience
qui a dépassé tout ce qu'elle l'a connue
jusqu'ici nous est arrivé c'était le cas
en fait ils ont investi les lieux
c'est à dire que
vécu leur vie n'est pas comme d'habitude
parce qu'il ya des personnes dans la rue
donc avait pas possibilité de mendier de
récupérer à manger tout était fermé
davy rien en fait la vie rien donc ils
ont vécu en mode ultra violent en mode
de crise mais de bagua en mode saas et
les voitures en mode vol d'un de c'était
d'une violence inouïe
enfermé dans son appartement corinne a
traversé le confinement seul avec ses
peurs et ses incompréhensions
je ne comprends pas en fait dans une
situation telle qu'on l'a vécu pendant
le covin avec effectivement le fait de
dire ne sortait pas toutes été
réglementée attention à l'hygiène y
avait effectivement une espèce de vannes
espace y avait une réalité effectivement
de faire très attention à ce virus
il y avait dehors des gens dont personne
ne s'occupait en fait il ya vraiment des
gens qui sont pas qu'ils sont vraiment
pas bien si kia traitement en fait on
est au delà de du social ou la détresse
c'est des gens qui ont un pet au casque
1 comme on dit et ça c'est dangereux
votre quartier malheureusement c'est
celui qui a concentré 100% du problème
c'est à dire qu'il ya eu des jours ici
où on a eu 100 % des toxicomanes
d'ile-de-france qui étaient réunis 100%
aucun autre endroit de réussissait
toxicomanes du graff qu'ils étaient là
comme pour envoyer des signaux vers
l'extérieur corinne a montré sur les
réseaux sociaux
le spectacle depuis son balcon c'était
ça t'as qu'à un type qui s'est mis en
plein milieu de la route façon là on le
voilà en train de filmer son crâne
voilà et puis beaucoup de deux
agressions par rapport aux riverains de
deux manières de réagir en fait là vu
que je filmais donc je me suis fait
insulter quoi bon par exemple
[Musique]
les riverains ont partagé ces images et
en ont publié aussi d'y aller sur
twitter et je voyais donc des vidéos je
me disais mais à lui vraiment juste là
en fait où une photo j avais ces
personnes est là donc on se connecte et
c'est comme ça que vous êtes fait
connaître c'est comme ça que je vous ai
connu c'est comme ça que de plus en plus
de gens ont réussi à rendre compte de
cette réalité et ça ça et ça joue un
rôle très fort et compris politiquement
oui je pense
avec pour toute arme leur smartphone les
habitants ont organisé la réplique c'est
ainsi qu'une forme de brigades de
quartier s'est constitué
vas-y films hors films d'or fut dans
cette rue bien sûr je me fiais mouais on
n'en peut plus on n'en peut plus des
ventes chez vous comme vous dans cette
rue parmi ces lanceurs d'alert voici le
plus organisé
il apparaît masqué tourner en caméra
cachée et son compte s'appelle stallings
craquer c'est une allusion à la place de
stalingrad points de vente notoire du
19e arrondissement
là c'est un peu le plein tube y dédient
leurs cercueils en pâtit ils ont fermé
les arcades mais on enlève tout le temps
ces barrières et c'est ici où ils se
cachent pour dîner mais ils sont
parfaits une trentaine dans leurs 40 m
je lance ma caméra et quand c'est pour
eux plus près ce passé je fais semblant
de téléphoner les avance tout doucement
et après je recadre en fait dans l'image
nous sommes en paix je dépose je mets
mon bras le long du corps mais je peux
marcher tranquillement quand il a publié
ainsi des dizaines de vidéos et pendant
le confinement dans ses commentaires
il a interpellé les policiers ouais j'ai
personnellement j'ai zappé trois fois
les trois fois et m'ont dit on va pas
venir pour les toxicomanes ont été
abandonnées tout simplement ça avait mis
un petit coup de pression à tout le
monde de savoir que voilà des riverains
pouvait s'organiser et ça on a vu que ça
avait fait bouger les choses
lui aussi est en contact avec mounir
mahjoubi le député a entendu son message
sur les forces de l'ordre
j'ai rencontré la commissaire je parle
avec le prêter et on a parlé de
l'efficacité d'actions sur le terrain
vous avez trop de policiers qui avaient
pas pour d'autres et d'agir ou de se
présenter face aux dealers depuis
quelques temps on voit qu'ils vont plus
au contact reproche d'être fier de venir
aux policiers ce qui doit faire c'est le
rôle du député de contrôler l'action
d'état partout via l'état et selon le
député de dire humblement au service
attacks on les dirige pas ces exécutifs
qui les dirigent nous représente le
peuple et les habitants on peut leur
dire on a l'impression que sur
l'utilisation des moyens de l'état
ici on n'est pas à la meilleure
efficacité mais l'ancien secrétaire
d'état au numérique ne s'est pas
contenté de rencontrer le préfet il a
aussi interpellé publiquement dans cette
lettre ouverte
un document appelé le pacte de
stalingrad où ils demandent davantage de
contrôles de police et d'interpellation
suppositions jaurès
c
depuis le 25 mai les policiers ont pour
consigne d' intensifier leur présence
sur le terrain il n'hésite pas à le
montrer
séquence interpellation astana
faut-il y voir une réponse à la
mobilisation des riverains et du député
les vidéos semblent avoir produit leurs
effets france que ragon des riverains il
à ses anciens après vingt ans j'ai
l'impression c'est plus les nouveaux
moyens d'expression et vos moyens de
communication qui font que
laure leurs revendications étaient
encore plus visible la tolérance zéro en
réponse aux critiques des habitants
les toxicomanes en train de consommer
sont plus souvent contrôlés et arrêtés
cette femme par exemple est interpellée
en train de fumer
c'est quoi
la petite échoppe
elle est emmenée au poste
si le test confirme qu'il s'agit de
craquer non de doliprane
elle sera immédiatement déférés le test
déjà l'intérieur parmi les toxicomanes
sont ensuite condamné à une injonction
de soins et une interdiction de
retourner dans le quartier c'est ce que
prévoit un nouveau plan d'action
judiciaire du parquet et de la
préfecture de paris
en un mois la police a réalisé cent
trente-neuf interpellations mais elle
prévient elle ne réglera pas seul la
question du crack sur la place de la
bataille de stalingrad on l'a dans
l'éviction et
et la lutte contre les phénomènes de
toxicomanie oprah qu on est nous sommes
tout seul alors que la problématique
n'est pas que policière c'est sur la
police que repose le règlement du
problème
vous pourriez meilleure prise en compte
médicale
dekra que peut-être plus de moyens
injectés dans la lutte contre la
consommation de crack et des efforts
supplémentaires pour les soins on
pourrait être prodigués aux
aux toxicomanes le social et le médical
c'est aussi dans le pacte de stalingrad
proposé par mounir mahjoubi seulement
cette fois les sujets relèvent de la
mairie est là le dialogue est beaucoup
plus difficile
le député n'hésite pas à le faire savoir
très heureux de vous retrouver bonjour m
et enchanté merci nanou et bonjour à
tous les taxis aussi bon jour à tout ça
va pour gilles on est près de 70 il est
17 heures 35
on avait dit 17h30 je pense qu'on peut
démarrer alors de sa permanence s'ils
organisent un fils book live c'est une
visioconférence avec les habitants sur
le thème du crack
il en profite pour faire passer ses
messages sur le maire socialiste de
l'arrondissement
monsieur gagnon et madame hidalgo ne
répond pas sur le sujet stalingrad
moi je crois qu'ils sont dépassés par la
situation je crois qu'ils ont
sincèrement cru que le problème ne
pouvait être que sécuritaire et ont
voulu mettre la pression sur le
gouvernement en disant c'est la faute au
gouvernement c'est la faute aux préfets
sauf que depuis plusieurs semaines
plusieurs mois et bien la police est au
rendez vous le préfet est au rendez-vous
le ministre est au rendez vous la
commissaire est au rendez vous il faut
que la mairie soit au rendez vous
ces critiques n'ont pas semblé atteindre
la mairie d'arrondissement qui
communiquent peu sur le sujet le député
touche ici aux limites de son périmètre
d'action alerté proposé médiatiser la
recette mahjoubi fonctionne parfois mais
pas à tous les coups
[Musique]